I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
have you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work it was a fabulous dinner until
you two uh mooned us thank God for talk
TV is not only the home of common sense
it's the only place where you get the
[Music]
truth
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV well good evening to peers Morgan
uncensored live from New York
City I'll be joined tonight by
Ambassador Mark Reger the senior advisor
to Israel prime minister Netanyahu and
former Ambassador United Kingdom he'll
be joining me live from Tel
Aviv also coming up will be British
rapper low key one of the most
influential and sometimes controversial
voices in the Pro Palestinian movement
he's uncensored as well live from New
York
[Music]
City Live From New York this is Pierce
Morgan
uncensored good evening New York and
welcome to Pi Morgan on sensor most of
the world stood in lock step with Israel
after the attacks October the 7th anyone
with a shred of human has condemned
those attacks for what they were a
barbaric terrorist Massacre of innocent
people and the biggest Slaughter of
Jewish people since the Holocaust but
more than two weeks on when grief now
turned to anger Israel is facing
difficult questions of its own almost
6,000 people in Gaza have been
reportedly killed according to the Hamas
run authorities that death toll will
surely soore with any ground Invasion
and those of us who had the basic human
compassion to be sickened by October the
7th should also be horrified by the loss
of innocent lives in Gaza too President
Ma France visited Israel today and said
this the fight must be merciless but not
without
rules because we are democracies which
fight against
terrorists well he's right rules matter
they're what separate the enlightened
World from the terrorists who want to
rip it apart targeting civilians as
Hamas did is a war crime but how can
Israel invade Gaza to remove Hamas
without killing many many civilians
Hamas is merciless Hamas sees death as
the beginning not the end Hamas makes
Martyrs of its dead they won't hesitate
to use his own civilians as human
Shields they're firing Rockets from the
grounds of schools mosques un buildings
guards was a Labyrinth of tunnels with
families packed into cities like
sardines how can Israel possibly invade
Gaza while maintaining the distinction
between civilians and combatants which
it must do under humanitarian law how
far can Israel go before it loses
international support when would it
allow proper Aid to Palestinian
civilians how can Israel invade without
jeopardizing the lives of the hostages
who are still
trapped well today two more of those
hostages were released by the Spin from
those now vaunting how well hostages say
they were treated Hass seiz these
innocent people from their homes and
held them as prisoners while
slaughtering 1500 others they're nothing
more than bargaining chips now in its
sick Conquest I fully support Israel
removing every last trace of Hamas but
even if it succeeds in doing that there
will only be more questions what happens
to Gaza after that Israel could wage a
war to decapitate Hamas and leave Gaza
in total ruins relying on neighbors it
doesn't trust to pick up the pieces it
could occupy and repress Gaza sew meeds
for a new wave of hate it could
reinstall the toothless Palestinian
Authority which runs the West Bank even
though for years it's propped up Hamas
precisely to keep the Palestinians
divided as former president Obama warned
today some of Israel's actions now could
Harden pal attitudes for generations and
erode Global support for Israel I'll be
the first to admit I don't have all the
answers to these incredibly difficult
questions Israel undoubtedly faces an
existential threat Hamas wants to kill
as many Jewish people as it can all of
them if it could it has so Israel must
defend itself I know it cannot sacrifice
a Region's stability and breed the next
generation of terrorists either in the
process of that defense well that to
discuss the conflict in Israel joined by
retired army General and former CIA
director General David Petraeus General
great to have you on the program again
thank you very much indeed for joining
me are you uh confident that we will in
the next few days perhaps weeks see a
full-blown ground Invasion uh by Israeli
forces of
Gaza I think it is very very likely I
think it's essentially inescapable if
the mission for the military is to
destroy Hamas that can't be done from
the air uh and clear clearly then they
will face these enormous challenges that
you have described uh and I hope that as
part of announcing the onset of the
operation that there will also be a
vision provided for the Palestinians in
Gaza after Hamas is destroyed as you'll
recall when we did the surge in Iraq we
sought to separate the Sunni Arab
population from Al-Qaeda and the Sunni
insurgents and we laid out here's what
life could be like for you when they are
gone uh and I I think that has to be
done here as well I agree very much with
what you laid out Hamas has brought this
existential moment on them uh this is
their fault their horrific actions
keeping in mind that 1,400 innocent
Israeli citizens would equate to 50,000
Americans per capita so you we need to
keep this in perspective how significant
that has been for a country of 9.3
million people and the 200 hostages
would be 7,000 uh that so again the
magnitude of this to the Israelis the
recognition that you uh noted as well
that Hamas is founded on the notion of
destroying Israel and of killing as many
Jews as is possible I think there
there's no choice uh for the Israelis
but after further as ideally precise as
as possible air strikes uh because as
you note hearts and Minds will matter
here uh and they have to be very
conscious of that Urban combat is
inevitably destructive there are
inevitably innocent civilian lives lost
especially uh in a scenario that is as
challenging as this one an enemy who
doesn't wear a uniform uses human
Shields will use the hostages and that
role fights from with civilian
population 300 miles of underground
tunnels under Gaza City and and so forth
and so on so this will be a very very
hard fight inevitably destructive but
the Hope has to be that out of this will
come something better not just for
Israel but for the Palestinian people uh
in Gaza and so that vision of what
follows has to be sorted out and I think
it ideally would be announced at the
same time as they announc the ground
operation and I think there should be a
vision for the people the Palestinian
people in the West Bank as well I mean
you've written this fascinating and very
timely book conflict with Andrew Roberts
u in which I saw an interview you gave
last weekend I think it was in the
Sunday Times and you were talking about
the reality of these situations where
you can take a town or city as you did
in Iraq but the real problem may start
when you take a town or city in other
words once you assume control abely of
somewhere and assume for a moment that
Israel takes control of Gaza what do you
then do uh can be as difficult an issue
as getting in there it can be more
difficult for L and we experienced this
as a commander of the 1001st Airborne
Division and two star general during The
Invasion we took the first major city uh
we were ordered to do that three days of
very tough fighting the enemy collapsed
and I called my boss and I said hey I've
got good news and bad news good news is
we own Nai he asked what's the bad news
we own Nai what do you want us to do
with it and there wasn't a plan for that
we ended up having to leave military
forces for it but then we had an even
bigger challenge uh after we took
Baghdad toppled regime and the all the
bureaucrats we needed to run the country
melted away uh and again we had
inadequate postconflict planning in fact
inadequate would probably be charitable
and then we compounded that by pursuing
policies that increase the numbers of
individuals who had an incentive to
oppose the new Iraq rather than to
support it by firing the bath party all
the way down to the level of bureaucrats
we needed to run the country most of
them were Western educated uh and quite
secular and of course also fired the
Army without telling them how we would
enable them to provide for their
families so that also raises the issue
of conducting operations in ways that
don't create more bad guys uh than they
take off the street by their conduct and
again this all of these the Israeli
leaders are keenly aware uh of these
particular challenges these paradoxes uh
these difficulties of conducting
operations in very densely populated
urban areas against an enemy who we
should also note is willing to blow
himself up to take Israeli Soldiers with
him they will stop at as we saw in their
offens is it right and general it's
there is a theory that this is part of a
much bigger operation being conducted by
Iran that they have enabled and trained
and facilitated and armed Hamas to
commit an outrage so appalling on the
scale that we saw on October the 7th
that it deliberately gos Israel into
perhaps uh over responding wiping out
large chunks of Gaza uh causing huge
anger and resentment huge civilian
deaths uh de Dismantling in the process
all the moves that have been made to
normalization between Israel and
countries like Saudi Arabia and whatever
that this is all part of a grander plot
by by Iran do do you buy into that
theory as being potentially what's going
on here and should Israel be very wary
that it might be being lured into that
precise
trap um I think that's arguable uh so I
don't completely buy into it but
certainly Iran is sitting on the
sidelines having funded equipped
directed often trained uh surrogate
groups Hamas is one of those Hezbollah
in Lebanon an even more powerful one
Shia militias in Iraq and Syria uh the
houthis and Yemen again they have
enabled all of this whether there's a
truly Grand strategy uh such as you laid
out I think is certainly not not not
validated but it certainly is plausible
uh and so again the conundrum for Israel
is how to accomplish a mission that I
think does need to be performed the
destruction of Hamas and also their
allies Palestinian Islamic Jihad and as
you will have known uh the Israelis are
not just taking out these terrorist
groups they have also said they want to
dismantle uh the Moss political Wing
which means that they're going to take
down essentially the government uh of
this territory as well and that begs the
question okay who is going to take their
place uh that's a huge question uh you
noted the Palestinians in the West Bank
don't want to ride in on uh Israeli
tanks to take over the Optics of that
would be more than a little bit
difficult but there does have to be the
idea the vision for the future it can't
be left uh until later on or the
Israelis will end up owning it and that
prob probably will be very difficult as
well so again that has to be resolved
and let's keep in mind that what follows
the Hamas political Wing will not only
be handing out humanitarian assistance
and restoring basic services and
rebuilding damaged infrastructure uh
they're also going to have to have a
counterinsurgency element a a hard edge
with a lot of intelligence because there
will be remnants of Hamas and the
Islamic shihad that will try to
reconstitute and we have seen what
happens uh when an i is taken off a
group like the Islamic State we
destroyed them during The Surge kept
them uh down for three and a half years
after that our combat forces left the
Iraqis took their eye off on it and with
a couple of years you had a caliphate
the first ever in Northern Iraq and
Northeastern Syria we had to go back in
to help to advise assist and enable the
Iraqi security forces and the Syrian
Democratic forces to eliminate that
caliphate and to keep an eye on them
ever since so that's another aspect to
this that will be very challenging as
well General betrus uh as I say your
book couldn't be more timely it's called
conflict it details all manner of
conflicts and this is one of those where
it seems intractable right now but
history shows us that peace can be
forged if the right people have the
right mentality about it and I can only
hope and pray that is the case here and
that things don't escalate even further
than they already have I appreciate you
joining me thank you very much thank you
Piers well coming up the UN warns
Palestinians are facing disaster without
more fuel and Aid as they await the
Israeli ground offensive I'll talk to
Israeli spokesman mark regev That's
uncensored next live from
[Music]
newor
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to PB on censored live from
New York City I'm joined Now by
Ambassador Mart reg the senior advisor
to Israel prime minister Netanyahu and
former Ambassador to United Kingdom he
joins me live from Tel Aviv uh Mr Reg
thank you very much indeed for joining
me uh I wanted to start by uh reading
what Barack Obama the former US
president has come out and said in the
statement he said Israel has a right to
defend its citizens against such want
and violence but even as we support
Israel we should also be clear that how
Israel prosecutes this fight against
Hamas matters and it must abide by
international law he said the world is
watching and any Israeli military
strategy that ignores the human cost
could ultimately backfire already
thousands of Palestinians have been
killed in the bombing of Gaza many of
them children hundreds of thousands
forced from their homes the Israeli
government's decision to cut off food
water and electricity to a captive
civilian population threatens not only
to worsen a growing humanitarian crisis
could further Harden Palestinian
attitudes for Generations erode Global
support for Israel play into the hands
of Israel's enemies and undermine
long-term efforts to achieve peace and
stability in the region uh what's your
response to
that so there's a dilemma here on one
hand we want to hit Hamas and Destroy
its military machine and end its
political rule of over Gaza and at the
same time of course we don't want to see
the civilian population of Gaza suffer
unnecessarily in many ways they too are
victims of hamas's oppressive rule so
we've got to try to balance those two
and and what we're trying to do and you
can be the judge if we're succeeding or
not is we're trying to hit Kamas hard
ultimately to destroy Kamas and at the
same time offer as best we can solutions
to the civilian population of Gaza who
are not the targets of our
operation I guess what critics would say
is that 5 6,000 civilians in Gaza have
already been killed which is four times
as many uh has died in the appalling
Terror attacks of October the 7th uh and
that if there's a ground Invasion that
number will exponentially rise to
perhaps hundreds of thousands of
innocent Palestinian civilians and they
would question whether that is
proportionate uh and also they would say
well it's fine to say to Palestinian
people you got to get out of Northern
Gaza but if all their homes are getting
leveled in the process uh where do they
go back to where do these people live at
the end of this what happens to
them so so let's discuss what you've
raised number one when this is over I'm
sure there'll be a massive
reconstruction effort uh inside the Gaza
Strip to to to build homes that have
been destroyed and and I think there'll
be international support for that but we
have to destroy Hamas now I'd like to be
able to tell you peers that there won't
be civilian casualties to make a promise
yes there there won't be but that would
be illogical you've covered Wars you
know there hasn't been a war in modern
history where there haven't been
civilians caught up in the crossfire but
what we can do as a democratic country
is make a maximum effort to keep those
casualties as low as is humanly possible
now you're right when you say to me that
asking civilians to move from the north
to the South that's not easy a lot of
people it's very difficult for them to
move I understand that uh it's it can be
very threatening to ask people to move
they don't like moving but surely that
is in the real world that is preferable
to a situation where they're caught up
in the crossfire and and possibly be
casualties and they have moved in their
masses hundreds of thousands of people
have moved from the north to the South
and now our Challenge and we're working
with the International Community on this
is to see what humanitarian uh
facilities we can build in the South for
those internally displaced people and
we're we're Partners in that
one of the major issues you're going to
have and we just discussed this with
General David betrayers who knows better
than most what happened in both Iraq and
Afghanistan in response to 9/11 uh is
that you got to win hearts and minds of
the Palestinian people or ultimately
you'll just create more problems going
forward than you even have now how do
you win hearts and Minds if thousands of
these civilians are dying on a daily
basis that that surely will have the
opposite effect and like I say these
numbers are likely to dramatically
increase and World opinion you know
already uh is turning against Israel
which seems extraordinary so soon after
the scale of those Terror attacks but
you know that it is there's been some
very disturbing anti-Semitism that we've
seen around the world does it not
concern you that the strategy that
Israel is currently adopting coupled
with a potential ground Invasion
imminent
may actually have the opposite effect to
what you what you hope for that you get
rid of
Hamas perhaps but in the process you
create something far
worse so first of all I people are
describing Hamas and not Israelis
International leaders have described
Kamas as worse than
Isis and uh uh when the German
Chancellor was here last week he he said
they're like the
Nazis and so you ask what is worse than
Kamas I'm not sure there is a lot worse
than Kamas though maybe we'll be
surprised yes but I'm not sure that's
pretty low Kamas and I'm not sure you
can get a lot worse but can I can I
raise one issue that needs to be said
all the numbers coming out of Gaza about
civilian casualties they're all provided
by the Kamas controlled Ministry of
Health now as you know better than many
that Kamas doesn't have a democratic
rule there's no Civil Society
independent Civil Society in Gaza it's
an authoritarian regime
and if you would believe the numbers
coming out of Hamas I mean we're only
killing innocent civilians well
obviously that's not true they don't
even record a single Hamas fighter who
has been killed and now that's clearly
impossible I don't deny there have been
Innocents caught up in the conflict but
the numbers that are coming out that are
announced every day by the Hamas
controlled Ministry of of Health that's
clearly propaganda I mean once again
have have you heard a single
announcement about Combat fatalities on
their side or what I'd call terrorists
that we've killed not one well I think I
think well in a way in a way you've
highlighted one of the big problems
you're going to face going forward with
the ground Invasion how do you tell
somebody who's A combatant from a
civilian it's going to be incredibly
difficult you know General betrayus
again was talking about that let me ask
you you're an advisor to Benjamin
Netanyahu many Israelis I mean the
polling currently suggests that the
majority of Israelis are absolutely
Furious of what they see as him dropping
the ball in terms of security and
intelligence
uh enabling Hamas to commit this uh
outrage um many think he should have
resigned but he hasn't even apologized
publicly for those failings uh on
October the 7th why not first of all
Israelis are entitled to be angry I mean
they they they the Hamas a brutal enemy
CAU us unexpected surprised and there's
a whole series of failures I mean you
talk about at the top uh with with the
Prime Minister but there's a whole
series of of of failures that need to be
investigated why was it that our
intelligence didn't pick up on this
brutal attack before it happened I mean
we pride ourselves in Israel on having
excellent intelligence Services you know
we're very proud of our mad and shinb
and so forth and yet they took us by
surprise and that's you know Israelis
are asking what happened and then
there's how did they cross the fence at
so many points and and and succeed in
just coming and raiding our communities
I mean we spent a lot of money and
Technology we you know we were told many
times that the fence is impassible and
yet they just stormed it and came across
our side of the one of the reasons uh
one of the reasons Mr Reger that people
say the ball may have been dropped here
in such a spectacular and deadly manner
is because prime minister Netanyahu for
most of the year has been fighting Mass
Social protests and unrest over his
attempt as his critics put it to usurp
the authority of the Supreme Court and
that that has distracted defense and
intelligence operatives away from what
they should have been doing which is
protecting the Israeli people from
exactly the kind of attack that happened
on October the 7th and then for that
reason because it's all on netanyahu's
Watch and he's the one who's been waging
this attack on the Supreme Court's
Authority and creating the social unrest
uh that because of that he should take
personal accountability and step
aside so I think in many ways I mean we
Israelis as you you know have have been
having a very polarized political debate
uh we you know very passionate about our
politics in Israel and there are people
who hate the Prime Minister and there
are people who love the Prime Minister
and our society has had this very very
you know demonstrations against the
government and demonstrations for the
government and so forth but
maybe the Kamas the brutal Kamas
Massacre on on uh on October 7th that
was to a certain extent but slap across
the face because let's be frank I know
that part of the Southern Israel where
they they struck and they killed our
people but I mean frankly they massacred
our people yes they didn't ask us how we
vote they they went into kibuts which
are on the left yes and and they went
into stot which is a politically it's a
liid Bastion they don't care if you vote
left or right if you're secular or
religious if you're for or against the
government's proposed judicial reforms
they killed us they killed us randomly
they killed us brutally they beheaded us
they raped
they they they they burned people alive
you reported all this last night I don't
have to repeat the atrocities that were
committed and for israelies who who are
passionate about their politics and and
we like a good argument but this is a
wakeup call and that is why you saw a
major opposition party that has had
nothing nice to say about the Prime
Minister join the government for the
duration of the conflict this is a time
for Unity this is a time to win I mean
we didn't want this war they declared it
on us when their brutal attack but but
now we have to win this war and and
you've seen at the highest political
level an opp major opposition party
joining the government for the duration
and there will be a time when this is
over there'll be a time for politics
there'll be a time for Lessons Learned
after previous conflicts uh we've had
commissions of inquiries we've had all
sorts of Investigations uh parliamentary
investigations judicial legis
investigations I don't know what will
happen this time but it's for me as an
Israeli it's very important that if
there are lessons learned that we learn
those lessons yes what happened on uh
October 7th when they crossed the border
the way they did taking us by surprise
slaughtering our people that's clearly
something that needs to be examined very
thoroughly when it comes to the moral
line what is your red line in terms of
what Israel can do to get rid of Hamas
what what would be too far for you
that's what people are asking right now
they understand that Israel is in a rage
that the people are shocked they're in
trauma I've talked to Jewish friends of
mine who feel genuinely fearful and
traumatized by what has happened there's
no denying that and the protest the
anti-semitic nature of these protests
since has been uh repellent and also
adding to that fear but what is the red
line for Israel I mean is there a moral
line that you won't cross here or are
all bets off when it comes to getting
rid of
Hass first thing that needs to be said
is that as much as people are angry and
rightly so uh we haven't been shooting
for the hip and people have been talking
about this ground Invasion what is it
for 2 weeks now and it's still uh not
happened uh and so we are very thinking
steps ahead we're planning we're
preparing and we'll go in where we're
ready to go in we're not acting out of
Rage I mean we're angry but uh our
behavior is judicious and once again
we're looking not just what happens
tomorrow we're looking what happens next
week and next month and next year we're
thinking this through very carefully and
that's important to be said uh on the
larger issue uh um look when we send our
soldiers into Gaza we know they're going
to be facing a formidable enemy an enemy
that's fighting you know that's run the
Gaza Strip for the last 16 years they've
got bunkers they've got tunnels uh
they've got their defenses and are young
soldiers going into battle I'm telling
you openly we know not all of them will
come back alive it'll be very Fierce
fighting and then you raised the issue
of the hostages what will they do to the
hostages in the framework of such a
battle and then there's avoiding as much
as best you can civilian casualties
we've got all these issues but having
said that I spoke to some of our young
soldiers who who who are going into
battle and and look Israel understands
that this just needs to be done we have
to do it look we don't and refuse to
live anymore next to
this as a nextdoor neighbor and as was
said Hamas is in many ways worse than
Isis and I think if you ask me what is
our model what is our red
line we watched very carefully what the
West did what England and the United
States did in you know leading the fight
against Isis to destroy the territorial
control they had in parts of Syria and
Iraq they had what they called the
caliphate they had territorial control
they were removed and we will remove
them the same way now once again in the
fight against Isis there were innocent
civilians in places like mosul who who
who were caught up in the crossfire and
that's not a good thing but
unfortunately that happens in war and I
think we will model ourselves on the
same high standards as other Western
armies we'll fight our enemy ruthlessly
and do our best in a complex combat
situation to to safeguard the civilian
population as best as possible but if
some of the criticism is well you can't
do this because there will inevitably
cilian casualties no that didn't apply
in the fight against Al-Qaeda that
didn't apply in the fight against
we will do our best to minimize
casualties but if someone says you can't
destroy Hamas for fear of Civilian
casualties that doesn't apply to any
other country it doesn't apply to Israel
either M RV thank you very much indeed
for joining me my
pleasure well coming up next British
rapper low key is one of the most
influential and sometimes controversial
voices in the Pro Palestinian movement
he's uncensored next live from New York
City
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know I love about t
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the she I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of boozed up Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose I am
not stop ping to the nimes to the
naysayers and the national Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't
what he was most of them seem have given
up welcome to the talk it's really great
to be back my Little Darlings kids think
all they have to do is stay at home be
silly take pictures of everything just
shut down Tik Tok then
yeah problem
Sol fit as a butcher's dog there you go
he's fit as a butcher's dog him all
right but but he's now middle class here
test the knock on effect is far larger
than just CO2 I nearly have empathy when
I'm speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after
show call say I'm not I'm not a Swifty
critics I'd say me included got former
PMS all over the joint saying things the
last few days we have indeed yeah great
first show you having fun oh a ton of
fun King peer and King Cube I think it's
only room for one king man you know what
I'm saying just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're k F when I say I am
God you think I'm joking or not you tell
me I'm not joking I'd rather do it on
camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you had you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm
going to do you're going to resol yes
cuz I cannot continue my work it was a
fabulous dinner until you two uh mooned
us thank God for talk TV is not only the
home of common sense it's the only place
that we you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV welcome back to psbg on sensor live
from New York City where British Iraqi
rapper and pop Palestine activist Kareem
Dennis better known as low key has been
a powerful and influential Pro
Palestinian voice before and during this
conflict the official version of his
track terrorist was taken off YouTube
after the Hamas attacks October the 7th
14 years after its initial release he's
been highly critical what he says is
media bias and accuse me of taking a
pro-israel slant on this show well I'm
joined Now by Loki who's at our London
Studio Loki thank you very very much
indeed for joining me I appreciate it
thank you for having me
piss um I I mean on the issue whether
I'm pro- Israel I I don't have a horse
in this race or this War I try and be
balanced I try and have all kinds of
views I think we've had more Pro
Palestinian people on this show in the
last two weeks than any other new show
in the world they've be getting huge
audiences so I would take issue with
that charge that somehow I'm slanted one
way or another I think this whole thing
is a complete tragedy I know that you've
been committed to the plight of the
Palestinians for a long time going back
at least 15 years from what I can see in
terms of you traveling to Gaza um what
was your reaction when you first heard
about these attacks on October
7th well let's be clear reading the
testimony of survivors of October 7th
from kibuts bittery like Yas purat was
extremely harrowing what she alleges is
not only that her husband was killed in
the initial takeover but also she then
says that the Israeli military tanks
fired on the room where the hostages
were killing 12 Israeli civilian I
captives we have also seen fantastic
work in the haret newspaper by Amos
harell where he speaks at length about
uh Brigadier General Rosenfeld who was
in charge of the arett crossing now when
this military base was taken over what
he says Amos Harel in haret the
well-known Israeli newspaper he says
that Rosenfeld when he realized that the
base was overtaken called in an air
strike this is in haret these are not my
words these are the words of Amos Haro
what we then saw is since October the
7th 22 Israeli civilian detainees killed
in Gaza by Israeli air strikes the
Israeli military has something called
the Hannibal directive the Hannibal
directive was developed in Lebanon in
the80s by the Israelis with the clear
understanding that they do not want the
other side to to take hostages so for
example you have the case of um had gold
Golding in
2014 what Israel called operation
protective Edge which killed over 2,200
Palestinians but when uh this Israeli
soldier was taken captive by the
Palestinians Israel then proceeded to
kill everyone including the civilians in
the area around where he was kept and
the soldier himself self so what Israel
has unfortunately is a policy of killing
captives if you look at the case of
gilad shal this was an Israel so allow
me to finish allow me to finish you
can't just keep talking you can't keep
talking I have one last point to make
and I hope that you'll allow me to make
it in the case of gilad Shalit what
happened was one Israeli soldier led to
a thousand Palestinian prisoners being
released there is a clear understanding
within the Israel
military and political Elite that they
do not want people to be kidnapped so
therefore they
unfortunately as history has shown us
and as the directive within the Israeli
military shows they take action to kill
their own captives that have been taken
by the other side right let me let me
respond to you you tweeted on October
the 7th the arrogance to believe you
could keep 2 million trapped in an open
air prison indefinitely dot dot dot that
appears to have been your only comment
about what happened so just for the
record do you condemn what Hamas did
that day I condemn the genocidal
conditions which have created this
violence every heartbeat every human
heartbeat is sacred to me and that is
what has compelled me to work as I have
for the last 15 years to save lives to
save lives stop people dying but no we
do not have a clear picture of what
happened or October 7th because
unfortunately too much of the media has
relied on the Israeli military talking
points which are given directly to them
until neutral observers until neutral
observers are able to establish the
facts of October 7th I will not I will
not allow the talking points of the
Israeli military to become dominant of
what happened on that day Palestinians
are subject to a genocidal War
Collective punishment in Gaza is real
let me let me respond you are the only
Pro Palestinian person I've had on the
show in two weeks who has tried to make
out that this just didn't happen on
October the 7th or
somehow misrepresenting what I am saying
do you do you well I've got two
questions they're very straightforward
do you believe that 1500 people were
slaughtered including 260 people at a
music festival you're a musician and
secondly do you condemn the people who
did it they're not I would like to quote
something that you just said to the
former spokesperson for the IDF this was
your exact sentence not long ago you
said it's difficult to tell between
combatants and
non-combatants so you the implication of
what you said was somehow it was
understandable that Israel has killed a
Palestinian child every 15 minutes in
for the last somehow they couldn't tell
that those children were not combatants
according to you no I didn't say
understand I didn't say that and I have
said it absolutely appalling the number
of children who are dying in Gaza it's
appalling and it will get worse I make
no bones about that at all and I have to
say and I have to say but you have to
start you have to start surely from a
Humanity point of view I can absolutely
express my horror at the deaths of
Palestinian innocent civilians as I have
done many times over the years I think
it's horrifying uh and I think this is
why I I have a serious problem with the
proposed ground Invasion because I think
it will create uh unbelievably large
numbers of Civilian casualties and I'm
not sure that the strategy will work um
but I'm just curious why you who is I
know you care about people I know you
care passionately about the Palestinian
civilians but you're the only Pro
Palestine voice I've had who's even
tried to suggest that what Hamas did on
October the 7th was not as bad as we
think so is that what you think do we
think but what do we think is the
information is not clear as I've said to
you all human
life tried to hide it I'm not trying to
hide anything you're trying to hide
something no no with respect with
respect you are trying to you are
definitely trying to dissemble here and
I'll explain why I've given you an
opportunity to Simply say whether you
condemn what Hamas did which by the way
they have brazenly boasted about they
posted videos celebrating what they did
there is no doubt about what Hamas did
they want you to know what they did they
want me to know that they want the world
to know they killed Jewish people in the
Maine and in Israel with impunity 260
people at a music festival babies
grandmothers they kidnapped 200 people
God knows what's happened to them now
you can shake your head but what you
can't do is deny that that happened
because Hamas have admitted it brazenly
and
with and secondly if they if they've
admitted it do you condemn what they did
I absolutely mourn the loss of all human
life in this conflict and I have
struggled for 15 years of my life in a
way that appears to be honest you
haven't okay and I take you as an
empathetic person with a high level of
emotional intelligence okay I have
struggled for 15 years of my life to
Stop The Killing for a ceasefire now to
stop deaths but I have to say peers that
actually this this line of questioning
unfortunately on a personal level is
somewhat hypocritical and I'll explain
why on April 18th
2022 you said the exact phrase that you
feel like Nelson Mandela walking out of
prison on the long road to freedom of
speech today there is a statue for
Nelson Mandela outside Parliament now
Human Rights Watch amnesty International
bit Salim and even the Harvard Law
School have said that Israel practices
apartheid against the Palestinian people
do you know what thec struggle against
apartheid entailed are you aware that
thec are believed to have very
unfortunately horrifically and terribly
taken the live lives of children and
civilians in their struggle against
apartheid so peers you seem Absol
absolutely content to not only compare
yourself to Nelson Mandela who served 27
years in jail for what they described as
terrorism at the time but yet you cannot
see what the vast majority of Human
Rights organizations in the world see
when they look at the Palestinians when
you look at UN resolution
194 paragraph 11 the Palestinians have
the right to return home almost a
million of them were displaced in 1948
with the foundation of the state of
Israel and what we are now on the brink
of is Palestinians million of millions
of them being driven into the cide
desert with help of the US Delta
Force
briti a manfactured an Israeli
manufactured humanitarian catastrophe in
there is a 23% infant mortality let
me let me say something I completely
agree with you about the pl of the
Palestinian people I've tweeted about
this for the last two weeks no no to be
fair you haven't PE and this is not
journalism sh AB journalism y was
journalism M AA that's journalism
Palestinians are reaching out from the
cage that Israel has put them in and
they are trying to speak to the world
and they are being they are being met
with cold indifference and I would say
to you pe I would say to you that that
gentleman that you've just had on the
show Mark reg Mark regev he belongs in
the ha David patrus you know peers you
made your reputation as opposing the
invasion of Iraq well I would ask you
journalist to journalist how could you
justify the interview you just gave to
the head of US forces in that illegal
occupation of Iraq that David Petraeus
LED he was then the head of the CIA both
of the individuals that you have just
had on this show deserve to be in The
Hague tried for war crimes I am not
anything like them I have not hurt a fly
those two men have why are they given
the respectability that you gave them
with your interview and why am I
interrogated as if I am somehow someone
that could hurt a human being well
certainly in Mark Red's case I pushed
him hard on all the positions is Curr
adopting that wasn't hard let me explain
because I I did a tweet today and I I
meant every word of this I said I have
great respect for anybody who in the
immediate aftermath of this appalling
terror attack said it was outrageous and
appalling there are 1,500 Palestinians
still under the rub in Gaza exactly
you've had your say they're still under
the rub they're still under the rubble
you're not bringing them up I said those
I said those who whose instinctive
reaction was not to feel that and I
think you're one of them because your
reaction was to say the arrogance to
think you could keep 2 million people
trapped in an open air prison
indefinitely as if somehow that
justified what happened that day didn't
justify know exactly what you're doing
you should be able the point the point
when that tweet was sent the point when
that tweet was sent you had not seen
anything had happen you have had your
you've had your criticism of me and
that's fine you're perfectly entitled to
it like I said to you I all you said
about me I believe in free speech you're
entitled to your opinion of me of David
betrus of Mark reg but I'm also entitled
to judge you as somebody who did not
find it in themselves to express
anything involving any out I've just
expressed it and and and this is not
journalism the idea of us comparing our
moral compasses and somehow I have a
deficient moral compass somehow I am a
moral monster you know you know what's
true you know what's true is I am not
the people that have shown a cold
indifference to the ethnically cleansed
Palestinians dispossessed one in three
every Refugee in the world is
Palestinian they are the largest Refugee
population those who have turned a blind
eye to their suffering are those that
need to be seriously interrogated about
their moral compass and I would ask you
I would ask you before we end the show
no I would ask you that I am able to
read out the names of the 20 Palestinian
journalists that have been killed time
because I have two more guests
have 20 journalists so I'm beinged now
and I'll tell you something you're being
this badge this badge zoom in on this
badge this badge was given
by an employee of this building who said
they were told they could not this badge
because it was the Palestinian flag you
about uncensored this is sens this
badge employee in this building
told BGE so that's a ridiculous thing to
say I'm in New York uh but good to see
you loky I appreciate you coming on the
program well the panel after the uh
break to debate what just uh went down
there not sure we achieved very much uh
but we'll see what they thought
[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
welcome back to P I'm joined by my Pac
now the founder of within our lifetime
Nadine kiswani and the broadcaster and
journalist Emily Austin okay Emily what
did you make of that exchange I just had
with Loki I just just like how you ask a
clear clear-cut question and the
question never seems to be addressed on
any of your interviews quite frankly it
seems like they use the airtime as an
opportunity to deny the question and
just spread their own narrative and it
just it's it's pointless the debate is
pointless it's it's a one-sided
conversation and there's no actual
conversation it's here's my question oh
but what about this pin right I mean n
my problem with it is I've interviewed
some Pro Palestinian voices in the last
two weeks who were emphatic immediately
let me make it clear what happened on
October the 7th was a disgusting
terrorist attack an Abomination and then
they go on to talk about the plot of the
Palestinian people and maybe the
historical conflict and so on and I have
great respect for people that do that
I've got to say I really struggle with
anyone who just cannot have the humanity
to start by saying what happened on
October the 7th was appalling an outrage
do you feel it was I think pal Ians are
tired of that being the starting point
constantly when right now there are
6,000 Palestinians who have been killed
in Gaza over 2500 of them children 33
mosques leveled hospitals leveled so
we're tired of that being the the main
goal of the conversation the main goal
it's the starting point of this war but
hang on it's the starting point of this
war it's not the main goal of what I
want the conversation to be starting
point was when 750,000 Palestinians were
ethnically cleansed were expelled from
their Homeland
during the neba which my grandparents
which my
grandparents uh fled Palestine because
of the neba because of the massacres and
the rapes that they heard so to me
that's the starting point that's my
experience let's go with that for a
minute let's start with the nakba
because the only knba is the part that
people forget to address 1948 after the
partition plan the Jewish State called
in the Arabs to live prosperously and
peacefully in the land but what happened
the very next day not even 24 hours
later is the alleged nakba where the
Arab leagues declared war on the the
Jewish state that we just agreed to have
our two-state solution and what did they
tell their people leave the state let us
get the land back let's ethnically
cleanse the Jewish people and once we
defeat them in this war you will come
back to the land so the only knockout
was a catastrophe that you guys the Arab
leagues waged a war that you could not
win and that is why I'm sorry your
grandparents had to leave their homes
that's completely ahistorical I don't
represent the Arab League I'm
Palestinian and I'm speaking on behalf
of the Palestinian why do you find it
hard to just stop give this war this
latest War that's erupted began with a
terror attack on October the 7th why is
it hard to not just say that was
terrible I don't see you asking reg if
he condemned the slaughter of innocent
civilian she can't do it can you no she
can't because she's the same woman who
said every Zionist before they die she'
hear pop pop before they die so she
probably agrees with the massacre so why
would she condemn them I think we're the
media is part of manufacturing consent
talk I'm speaking here and I don't I'm
not interested in speaking to genoci
deniers the media is manufacturing
consent for genocide against the
Palestinian people just like they did
with the LIE of the weapons of mass
destruction that was used to justify the
murder of over a million Iraqis and
there's been many lies that have been
repeated all over the news including on
your show where CNN had to resend and
even you said in subsequent interviews
about the 40 beheaded babies I haven't
seen a single sh I have not seen a
single shred of evidence about these
accusations coming
out I was actually deliberately
misquoted but look we got to leave it
there for the Hang on we're going to
take a little pause that's the end of
our television program tonight we're
going to continue this discussion on our
YouTube channel but keep it unsensored
we're going to keep it unsensored and
keep this conversation going because I
find it genuinely
[Music]
fascinating
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent Republican Mike
gra right here on talk TV welcome to
Friday night with Nadine here on prime
time we like to speak to the business
people behind big moments good evening
I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in New York
City very impressive well played
I'm 3 days into the job what have I done
wrong and your face just starred out at
me me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about toour
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pump you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose
L stop handing to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing labor would be Terri